make of thyselves
that which he desire
be as a lord
be as a god
but should he fail to become ought at
all you will be forsaken
amounting only to sacrifices
[Music]
in the beginning all life was once
blended together
beasts serpents and dragons ruled the
land
over time they evolved and with
intelligence civilization began to
establish itself across the
realm but one day everything changed
when an outer god called the greater
will sent a golden star bearing a beast
into the lands between
which later would become
the elden ring
an outer god is a source of power with
origins that are not of this world
in order to watch over the world an
outer god selects an emperian to become
a god and rule over the world
this emperion in turn becomes the ultra
god's chosen vessel
an emperion is no mere demigod and has
the power to become a new god and forge
a new order across the land
the imperium that is selected by an
outer god must also take a lord as their
consort and is given a shadow to do
their bidding
and with the lands between the emperian
murica was selected by the great will
and she in turn chose godfrey a fearsome
warrior to be a lord with malakath
serving as a shadow
marika and godfrey had three demigod
children
godwin the golden and the twins morgot
the omen king and moog lord of blood
morgot and moog were cursed as omens and
were hidden in the depths below the
capital
the elden beast soon became the elden
ring
and marika became the ring's vessel
with marika now a god she used the elden
ring to give the earth tree power which
originated from the golden grace of the
greater will
and thus ushering the age of the earth
tree
the age of the earth tree began amongst
much conflict
maraca had godfrey lead a war against
the hostile factions of the world
and one of these were the fire giants
the fire giants possessed the flame of
ruin a flame that could burn even the
earth tree
so to eliminate this risk marika
launched an attack against the giants in
order to subdue the flame
by the end of the war only one fire
giant remained
and was cursed with protecting the flame
of ruin which can never be completely
put out
during the battle the fire giant's god
was also destroyed
by marika herself
a god in her own right queen marika
desired a world free of distant death
and decided that in order to accomplish
this to tamper with the elden ring
the ring is made up of a number of great
runes and marika pulled the rune of
death from the elden ring essentially
removing the concept of death from the
lands between
she would then give this to a loyal
shadow malekith to hold onto and keep it
safe
as stated the age of the earth tree
began amongst much conflict
america's golden army had been
successful in many wars across the land
but have been unable to claim victory
over the leonian forces
this conflict set the forces of the
golden order against the kharian royals
and the academy of lucaria
the lyrian were the descendants of early
astrologers and they sought power from
the stars and from the full moon
courtesy of the carrion leader ranala
instead of a defeat by one side the
leonian wars would eventually end with
the union and marriage of radagon the
champion of the golden order and rinala
rinala and radagon would go on to have
three children
rani radhan
and reichard
eventually america would start to doubt
and question the golden order
she wanted to search the depths of the
golden order their faith and their
beliefs
her goal being that she wanted to learn
more about what was behind the greater
will
while the age of the earth tree began
amongst conflict
at some point there was no longer any
worthy enemy left for godfrey
and it was said that his warrior spirit
left him along with his grace
the light surrounding his body and the
energy provided by the earth tree fled
god free spirit
leaving him broken
having been rejected by the earth tree
murica had little choice but to exile
godfrey from the lands between
making him the first tarnished
with this godfrey also lost his elden
lordship title and a number of his
people also became tarnished
following his fate they too no longer
had the life force of the earth tree
running through them
however with godfrey exiled maraca chose
radagon to become the next elden lord
leaving rinala behind
through this union redigon's children
rani radhan and reichard were to become
demigods
together maraca and radagon also
produced two more offspring mekwella and
millenia
however both were born cursed
millennia with a rotting sickness
and mequela with eternal childhood
but the true significance of this
marriage wouldn't be realised until much
later on where it would be revealed that
radigan and marika
are one and the same
it isn't clear whether radagon is marika
or that he simply became her later on
but regardless there is one thing that
is certain
his
her offspring
mikwela and millenia were born of a
single god meaning that they too were
emperion
they were eligible to be chosen by the
greater will
to become america's successor
the loss of radagon had ranala fall into
a dark pit of despair
she was broken
this led to the outbreak of the civil
war in lunalia where the academy
rebelled against the royal family
however her daughter rani would go on to
steal a shard of the ruin of death from
malakath
and shared it with the assassins hailing
from the eternal city
in an event called the night of the
black knives the assassins killed a
number of demigods with the first one
being godwin the golden
maracas first born
the death of marika's golden sun is said
to have been the beginning of what was
to come
mikwella would go on to turn his back on
the golden order
after finding out that it was unable to
treat his sister millennia's rock curse
he created unalloyed gold that he would
use to craft needles capable of warding
away the meddling of outer gods and
which could delay the rotting sickness
after the night of the black knives the
threat of other gods and with her two
children makwella and millennia turning
their backs on the golden order marika
was pushed to the brink
in clear defiance of the greater will
murica lifted her hammer and shattered
the elden ring
while radagon simultaneously tried and
failed to repair it in an attempt to
remove murica as its vessel
as punishment the greater will would go
on to imprison murica along with radagon
in the erd tree
with the elden ring shattered marika's
remaining children claimed the shards of
the elden ring in the form of great
runes
but instead of banding together they
would fight amongst themselves in a war
known as the shattering
many fierce battles between demigods
took place
with even the capital of landell being
put under siege
but the end result of the war was a
stalemate between numerous factions
many demigods now have great runes
scavenged from the damaged elden ring
that none have properly risen to power
to either replace america or become the
new elden lord
due to the shattering the greater will
gave the tarnished the grace of gold
once again and called upon them to
return to the lands between
they were given a goal men to the elden
ring and become the elden lord
fixing the shattered order of the world
it has been many years since the tarnish
were called back to the lands between
and while there have been countless
individuals who have taken up the
challenge none of them have been
powerful enough to repair the elden ring
and take their place as the new elden
lord
that is until one particular tarnished
soul came along
in the chapel of anticipation this
tarnished is revived by grace soon after
taking their first steps into the lands
between and eventually meeting melina
melinda offers herself as their maiden
able to transfer rune fragments into
strength
in exchange she asks for one thing to be
taken to the foot of the earth tree
over time melaner takes the tarnish to
the round table hold where other
tarnished champions reside
one by the name of gideon instructs that
to become a member great runes must be
acquired from the demigods from the
lands between to repair the elden ring
from there the tarnished can continue
towards the capital lane del
at the base of the earth tree morgot the
omen king is blocking the path and must
be slain to progress any further
however it is found that the earth tree
thorns are impenetrable and successfully
locking the elden ring inside
melinda instructs the only way in is to
travel to the mountaintops of the fire
giants and onto the forge the forge
contains the flame that can burn the
earth tree
after defeating the last fire giant
melano offers herself as the source to
ignite the earth tree
but it isn't enough the path is still
blocked
however the burning of the tree was
enough to have the tarnished hero
transported to a region called crumbling
far room azula
after fighting through numerous foes
malikith appears once malachith is
defeated the power of the distant death
is unleashed
the earth tree then begins to burn
bright red removing the thorns that
blocked the path towards the elden ring
returning to lane del gideon the
all-knowing confronts the champion
he is there to stop him becoming the new
elden lord
gideon is overcome by the tarnished
clearing the way to the entrance of the
earth tree
but before entering godfrey the first
elden lord must be removed
godfrey fails to defeat the tarnished
but before the elden ring can be mended
there is one more obstacle in the way
marika can be found crucified in a rune
arc
sensing the approaching tarnished
champion she transforms into redogon
preparing for combat
eventually radagon transforms into the
elden beast
but once again the tarnished proves too
much defeating the elden beast
the tarnished champion is now free to
repair the elden ring and become the
next elden lord
[Music]
elden ring has six possible endings each
determined by the paths that are taken
throughout the game
of the six endings the player will take
up the mantle of the elden lord in all
but two
but like many things in elden ring this
ending is not quite as straightforward
as it seems there certainly isn't a
right way to end elden ring and the full
meaning of each of them will likely be
debated over the coming months or even
years
this all follows the narration style
that from software has become known for
in their previous titles where the law
is complicated and often deeply hidden
within the game
for this reason i won't be going into
depth on these in this video as i don't
believe i'm currently in a position
where i can do them justice
in fact every time i look into a
particular piece of the story i end up
drawing slightly different conclusions
i often find myself revisiting certain
aspects because they seemed a little too
straightforward that i must have surely
missed something
but i think this is part of what makes
the lore of this title so deep and
interesting albeit a little frustrating
at times
i imagine i'll look into this video in a
month's time and have a completely
different outlook on how some of this
played out
to be fair there is still a lot of
details regarding the story that weren't
explored in the summary but even though
this might not explain everything i hope
this gives you a better idea of what's
going on in the story of eldon ring
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch in the next one cheers
you